chief White House correspondent John
Roberts starts us off tonight a busy day
again from the North Lawn John as usual
Brett we wouldn't have it any other way
late today the Homeland Security
Secretary Kirsten Nielsen appeared here
at the White House appointed to a
dramatic increase in the number of
people who have been crossing the border
illegally more than 50,000 a month for
the past three months at a 400% increase
in the number of so-called family units
but the new administration practice of
criminally prosecuting people who come
across the border illegally has created
a very large political problem for the
White House with the storm of outrage
growing over the separation of children
from illegal immigrants President Trump
today laid the blame squarely on the
Democrats I say it's very strongly the
Democrats fault their obstruction yeah
they're really obstructionist and they
are obstructing Democrats are outraged
at the administration's zero-tolerance
policy at the border where people who
cross illegally are held for criminal
prosecution and separated from any
children they may have brought with them
even some Republicans are critical in a
Washington Post op-ed former first lady
Laura Bush wrote this zero tolerance
policy is cruel it is immoral and it
breaks my heart
president Trump insists he was forced to
implement the policy after a dramatic
increase in the number of people some of
them criminals crossing the border with
children in tow the United States will
not be a migrant camp and it will not be
a refugee holding facility we can't
allow that to happen to the United
States not on my watch administration
officials say they are merely enforcing
laws that are already on the books
something they say previous White
House's failed to do but the political
firestorm has heated to the point that
the DHS secretary handled a late day
briefing at the White House Congress and
the courts created this problem in
Congress alone
fix it until then we will enforce every
law we have on the books to defend the
sovereignty and security of the United
States the White House is calling on
Congress to change the laws and reduce
if not eliminate altogether the need to
separate children from their parents
across the administration officials will
keep up the pressure on lawmakers this
week members of Congress of the
Democratic side say that you are using
children as a leverage trying to get
them to take legislative action what do
you say I say that is a very cowardly
response it's clearly within their power
to make the laws and change the laws
they should do so President Trump also
weighed in on the inspector general's
report on the FBI clicking email
investigation as a set up to today's
congressional hearing the president
tweeting yesterday why was the FBI sick
loser Peter struck working on the
totally discredited Muller team of 13
angry and conflicted Democrats when
struck was giving crooked Hillary a free
pass yet telling his lover Laura Lisa
page that will stop Trump from becoming
president witch-hunt President Trump
insists the IG report proves there was
no collusion between his campaign and
Russia to influence the election but his
own FBI director today said the report
doesn't even address that I don't think
this report speaks to the Special
Counsel investigation Democrats also
accused the president of using the IG
report as a bludgeon to discredit the
Muller investigation with tweets like
Comey gave struck his marching orders
molar is commis best friend witch-hunt
he is distorting this report he is
weaponizing it to discredit the special
counsel and undermine the rule of law in
the United States of America the FBI
director also said today that he does
not believe that special counsel Robert
Muller is on a witch hunt asked about
that late today press secretary Sarah
sander said the president is firm in his
belief that the robert muller
investigation is indeed a witch hunt
Brett John Roberts live at the North
Lawn John thank you